what's going on guys
reject nation I do drag Alva here look
who's Madame channel I don't know what
he's through he's doing something I'm
Tara Eriksen hey Eriksen yeah you like
Kevin Hart right yeah he did on his wife
let's bring that up again he's still
really funny let's not drop his personal
life problems [ __ ] are funny not all
of them I mean just they can be I meant
to say can be in between those two words
that I just said previously have you
been night school Tara no well don't
believe in it Hart's going back tonight
school cool I'm excited
well what do you know that's all we need
to know let's do it got your headphones
on Tara yeah I got him on they feel nice
all right here we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh I wish I could my boss won't let me
hire you drop down a Piedmont hi
that was a couple credit shine
graduating I got to get my GED I'm the
principal of this school I can do
whatever I want
yo Rin how are you using the boys know
[Music]
[Music]
the editors had a lot of fun with that
[Music]
we're correct clinically down
[Music]
[Music]
it was very with keep whenever
Kevin Hardman he dominates these timber
January months right there dude it looks
pretty funny
it looks like a Kevin Hart movie I would
pay money to go see it and not use my
movie pass really - laughs this feels
like a movie pass kind of film - yeah I
feel like I wouldn't maybe if I really
needed to laughs cuz Tiffany Haddish
she's like my new favorite comedian and
her and her she's so funny
are you like can do that like Oh white
girl white girl like trying to try not
like a black girl yeah like PC yeah yeah
no she just happens to be a woman
happens to be black and I happen to like
her a lot I feel this you can go Kevin
Hart yourself okay can I say the real
word on here yeah but I prefer that yeah
good that's damn yellow dollar bills
signs keep getting in the way Jumanji I
just watched that the other day cuz I
was late to the game he's hilarious he's
hilarious I'm not too familiar with
Tiffany Haddish but she seems really
funny here I feel like she might have
shined Kevin Hart in this movie she
might like that whole bit when they're
like yeah I can imagine they just
improvise forever a lot of improv these
two had bringing their a-game to this
material man and they look like they're
having a great time it feels like the
movie just is gonna mainly rely on Kevin
Hart and her yeah they look like they're
gonna do a great job so even if this is
like an OK comedy I'm sure there's still
gonna be a lot of great laughs to be had
so is Kevin Hart gonna leave his
girlfriend for her that's the vibe I'm
getting see let's see give me a second
who turned over in the bed in lingerie
that is what slow it down yeah yeah that
looks for you let's do
freeze ray long reaction that is his
girlfriend that was Tiffany I think he's
girlfriend is hot as hell
I still think she's gonna leave her for
him for Tiffany mm-hmm yeah cuz
Tiffany's trying to help well it looks
like she's kind of unapproved
you know what this is a nice message in
a day and age where it's proven that
getting a college degree doesn't really
mean much in America anymore it's nice
to see Kevin Hart encouraging the youth
to go back to school even if it's at
night time to balance a job you said
that in a real white voice was it on
purpose you're doing the white voice too
I know you're not trying to but you are
don't matter kid you don't need to go to
school just watch trailers subscribe to
the real rejects people click
notification bells for everybody else
[Music]
our channel if there's one thing I'd
tell you about editing for a Tara
Eriksen video I have never had to lower
a volume so much for a guest more than I
had to do for Tara peeking all over the
peak in all over the place it's a lot of
lower and check out her channel it's
growing right now people find out why